so today I'm going to talk do a few
things um so usually start with a bit of
a motivation to explain the broader
project in which this all fits um and
what is the the motivation behind it
what is the open research agenda on
political lotteries um then the initial
research that Ali presented fits in
perfectly as an example so I won't go
over that again but I will talk instead
more about this initial research from an
experiment on online citizen assemblies
which is a project coauthored with uh
Dominic du at the University of insbrook
and Adam karashi at the University of
urp so I don't need to go into too much
detail here about the motivation we all
know that these um experiments with
citizen assemblies whereby randomly
drawn citizens are brought together to
deliberate are growing across the world
in different countries are gaining an
importance um and the question is what
we can learn about that a particular
topic on which they've been organized is
climate and how we can address climate
change there are lots of calls for and
also experiments with these randomly
drawn citizens assemblies but also
institutionalizing them into more
permanent chambers of parliaments um and
so with that shift where these groups
are sometimes given legislative
initiative or at least decision-making
Powers um come an important question and
it is what about the parties what about
um the sort of natural um ideological
leanings that people will have and what
are the incentives uh there uh to build
parties and the question then becomes
whether all these advantages that we
know exist from random citizen
assemblies can easily travel to such a
legislative Arena where we know that
Stakes are very high and party
affiliations come into play the broad
and general research question of the
broader project is not just better but
really how can lotteries as part of
legislative or Democratic institutions
widen access to governance to different
minorities and support equality in
democracies and so when people talk
about democracy and lotteries they often
go back way back in time uh same picture
here as we saw before today um of the
Clarian which if I remember well I saw
actually in eth you can still see it in
the museum um of the agura maybe c as
you can uh correct me if I'm wrong um
and so people go back to this
um of course Very prominent example we
have a lot of recent uh work that is
very fascinating on this particular case
but we know that lotteries were used in
different scenarios the um Italian
citizen rep City republics are very
often mentioned uh between the 14th and
17th century but there are others such
as in space in England and in
Switzerland at a local level um and many
others uh
still lotteries can be found as examples
as part of democratic government and
Republican government way back in time
and there's also some recent work which
uh gives a lot of examples uh on this
mainly theoretically uh or from a
broader historical overview so lotteries
were often used to select office holders
but then The Story Goes Mass elections
took over as more more people was were
getting involved as this this was
upscaled right um and so from lotteries
um democracies moved to elections to
organize uh the way to select office
holders and for a lot of people that are
thinking about um what is maybe going
wrong with democracy today this element
of citizen participation that was there
uh by lotteries is what is really
missing today um but what is not often
known or what is less well known is that
Lottery did not immediately disappear
and this story is an important story to
tell it did not immediately disappear in
modern democracy in fact they were used
extensively throughout democratizing
Europe and we don't know much about them
in our empirical democratization studies
and so addressing that is part of this
project that I will be working on in the
next uh five years together with Ali of
course so the questions that I ask is
did lotteries really widen access to
minorities and if they did so how was it
maybe the case that where lotteries were
used it really enabled Constitution
drafting given that such high stakes
were at play constitutions the shift to
uh democratic government which would
have consequences down the line for many
years and centuries as we know post hook
um what was the interaction with the
party system development uh which was
happening at the same time so what was
the interest of these parties that were
uh emerging at the time and how did that
structure the way that the lotteries
worked and are there maybe long-term
consequences for political inequality
that we've maybe underestimated because
we've sort of Forgotten these peculiar
procedures um so the methodology of the
project is historical to check each uh
natural experiment uh separately and
then place that together with online
experiments today in a comparative
perspective um and you can think of
examples where this happened in onot
cases as in the example of Denmark we
saw today but it also happened in more
modern legislatur as we have some work
on uh in the past where this happened
repeatedly over time and it's of course
particularly there that you need to
think about party System Dynamics and uh
the Dynamics of using lotteries
repeatedly over time and which actors
have an interest in capturing that
process
so the example today is really this
constituent assembly in Denmark where
you had lotteries determining the
different committees who then met and
discussed and prepared the Constitution
and the draft of the
Constitution um and the idea is to put
all these different examples into a
comparative analysis um to study the use
also the reasons for the abolishment and
the effects of what we call these
Lottery based procedures across
countries uh and time and so the
important hypothesis are sort of listed
here one idea is that they are really
used in context I cannot emphasize this
enough where conflict is really high
yeah if conflict is not that important
then there are better and more efficient
ways of organizing political decision-
making so when there's High distrust
when party systems are splintered when
it's not clear who the opposition is
like who belongs to which party maybe
and when you have huge for example
inequalities as you had in the 19th
century of course this is a scenario
where lotteries might be used by actors
and might be successful I say might
because it
depends then the second thing to study
is to think about is whether these
lotteries really opened access to the
decision- making process as we assume
that lotteries do because that's in
their very Nature by randomly drawing
individuals you equalize opportunity of
access to all you strengthen the
minorities who may otherwise be easily
ignored so the question there is whether
when you open this AIS are there
long-term consequences does that work by
leveling political inequality uh in
political selection for example does it
work through the types of decisions that
are made in this legislature and how
does that translate into Evolution over
time so the three main hypothesis are
some summarized here so first um when
it's used in highly um conflictual
situations it might be precisely useful
for enabling collaboration to exist in
the first place um so for example um the
procedures that we used in this one shot
fashion in constituent assemblies it
might enable party system development
over time because you have a procedure
in place while these parties emerge and
thirdly once these parties become
stronger they will prefer a more
efficient procedure and they might move
to AB abolish these uh procedures that
you can test by looking at these uh
procedures in repeated legislative
assemblies and it's important to
understand the long-term effects on
politic inequality from this broader
academic um point of view right to
understand what is really going on uh on
the long in the long term uh when we use
such procedures so method Wise It's a
lot of lot of data collection that
hasn't been done before so it's using
information on 19th century legislatures
uh the way they voted uh the
characteristics they had um sometimes
they weren't even informalized parties
Etc and then for each natural experiment
the idea is to analyze each lottery in
country and over time uh to really check
whether it increased the diversity um of
the people involved in the political
debates did it do that um and then
secondly can we show that there are any
long-term effects either because it
affected the votes as you saw in the
Denmark case this morning um or because
it uh enabled party system development
or because it affected long-term
inequality now some of these um
lotteries can of course be a bit
limiting uh which is why we also want to
implement this in online experiments why
because we can control more of the of
the aspects of lotteries um we can of
course not go back in time in history
and change these things but to check
really whether you know the idea that
certain mechanisms are going on uh also
receives support in uh experiments today
and I'm finally putting this all
together in a comparative analysis uh to
uh inform successful Lottery design
today so and I've given this talk a
number of times so I know that you're
going to tell me but why why does this
matter so lessons from lotteries to
today why does it matter for today um if
you think about the example that Ali
presented this morning um you have
elected legislators being randomly
assigned to different committees and
what we saw there was very little room
for deliberation to really have a strong
effect yeah but at the same time Denmark
wrote a constitution right and the
Constitution remains in place today
so one comment is well elected
legislators are very different different
from ordinary citizens yeah um in this
constituent assembly you have a binding
decision very high stakes you have huge
inequalities uh and conflict low levels
of trust but consensus is really
important here right you will not
achieve a constitution unless you all
unless this is a broadly supported
process you really need consensus of all
the actors involved regardless of you
know their their particular stance on
specific
items of this
question and so this may be very
different from citizen assemblies today
it may be a particularly hard case to
discover any deliberation effects
because we know that partisan um um
beliefs are important here but actually
I would argue it's very similar to
today's problem about climate change
mitigation where you also have huge
inequalities between actors right
because because addressing climate
change will have huge redistributive uh
consequences it's a scenario where
consensus is very important for a
collective action where this needs to be
a decision um supported by a lot of
different uh actors and so we have
lessons to learn from these legislative
assemblies Lottery holds promises for
this deliberation to work but we need to
take Serious that the redistributive
effects May encourage strategic Behavior
you see it in some ways in the backlash
that some of these assemblies have had
uh in the past so I wanted to give you
this overview to let you know what the
project is about um but also to give a
good introduction of why I will now
present a slightly peculiar interesting
hopefully experiment so the idea was to
model a present day citizen assembly in
a very um abstract way but by
introducing Financial incentives as you
would in a behavior
experiments to really understand to be
able to predict what should happen and
to really understand what the mechanism
is in different
steps here in particular to introduce uh
strategic
Behavior so I will go onto that
now so how do people deliberate and
decide in strategic environments um here
we apply this to climate change
Collective action I mentioned how um
it's relevant and important because of
high stakes and because of the promises
that lotteries give us here for randomly
drawn decision makers there two aspects
in this experiment that are really
important for me in structuring um the
exercise one is that this is a group
decision right a lot of work has not
thought about the fact that this or I
mean experimental work I should say is a
group decision and secondly costs costs
are also very important uh when you
think about citizen assemblies
you need to think about how uh people
interpret this in terms of um what it
has real costs for them so in this
experiment people are allowed to share
if they want to they're not you know
it's voluntary they're allowed to share
their beliefs and opinions in an online
group discussion but I'm controlling
certain parameters of this interaction
to really understand what you should
theoretically predict or should
theoretically find um in such a setup
and the initial results that I will tell
you about today come from a pilot
experiment that I run where we find that
if you tell people before going into the
deliberation that a vote is going to
come up which is costly for them it
changes the decision- making process it
changes their behavior and changes the
outcome
yeah
okay so we know a lot about deliberation
we also know a lot about how people
think about addressing climate change
from existing literature and this is
just a slide with three different
important parts from the experimental
literature um on climate change
deliberation so first of all the
experimental literature on citizen
assemblies and within deliberative
democracy is positive mostly positive
showing that individuals really learn
they really intensively deliberate they
pick up information and they
successfully take Collective action
against climate change yeah there are a
few studies that find null results or
opposite effects but overwhelmingly
positive um
evidence the thing with these assemblies
is that they're very often advisory and
so their decision that they take is not
costly to the people involved uh not
directly costly um because it's not
binding because it's advisory and more
things happen uh down the line um and
what we also know from this literature
is that the way this conversation takes
place or the quality of this convers
conversation is really important so it
has to be well moderated uh people have
to be able to really um um Express uh
their minds Etc what the literature also
shows is that if you increase the
complexity of this interaction or you
ask people uh to take a binding decision
in a vot or or something like that um it
becomes more difficult to achieve these
difficult these um beneficial
outcomes so if we make this decision
binding that's a scenario where we
should really uh um expect strategic
behavior um and this is a good model of
thinking about you know parties
developing in such
environments the second part of the
literature that is relevant and
important is the literature that looks
at climate change mitigation um and when
people support this they
find a lot of people support climate
change mitigation but what it really is
conditional on how to what extent they
will be affected themselves so the cost
um um they're supportive as long as the
costs are low and that is of course
related to their pre-existing economic
vulnerability to these um um changing uh
measures uh to their ideology altruism
egalitarian preferences and so on but
what these uh studies and the next ones
also ignore is that in um these types of
decision making processes this decisions
are taken collectively so from
behavioral experiments we also know that
um we can think about climate change as
a public bad and people tend to under
invest in it yeah so what is important
for us given that we know all this what
is it that we really want to distill one
it's it has to be a group decision yeah
and there costs have to be uh
substantively there have to be costs
over substantively meaningful
choices so I hope I've now sufficiently
um motivated this experiment and I will
now go into the details and and unleash
the critiques um so our experiment was
pre-registered it's a pilot that took
place in the lab because it's a pilot
and because we understand and know that
there are a lot of difficulties involved
with encouraging good deliberation
online but people came to the
experimental lab and were assigned a
workstation and entered into an online
deliberation with each other over Zoom
it allowed us to control video uh sound
quality and so on but they had uh an
actual interaction um
online it's an incentivized experiment
which means that after eliciting their
current carbon footprint we try to mimic
the real costs in the lab of saying that
you will reduce your pollution uh your
individual pollution and then the
question of course is is this
manipulation proof um will there be
changes to the deliberation and to the
outcomes so the experiment is
incentivized it's this type of
experiment but it's not incentivized to
stick to an original randomly assigned
Viewpoint that makes no sense when
you're talking about these types of
topics you want people to really Express
their health opinions and beliefs about
this so people are allowed to do that
and what we randomly assign is which
individuals are appointed to which
groups so participants would come into
the lab they would draw a number
a small little ball from a bag and some
of them would be sent home and some of
them entered the experiment so people
are randomly signed to the uh groups and
to the treatment as
well then we use their existing
pollution Behavior as they tell us it is
uh to stretch out this group on a scale
of income points so some stand to gain
or lose more than others in uh Financial
incentives I mean in this experiment the
topic is of course also important an
because people have to talk about
something that is substantively
Meaningful to them and here we decided
to follow uh the UK climate assembly and
we used their materials to make a really
brief really short um distillation um of
these materials and I'll show you later
um on either flights or food and that is
not to say at all that we think that
individuals can solve climate change by
you know their own changing own behavior
but what we want is that this
deliberation is substantively Meaningful
for them right and that they don't think
of these topics as well that's the
government's uh job not saying it isn't
I'm saying you know it's important that
they deliberate over something that they
can actually control yeah that the costs
are meaningful to them also as well not
just you know a strange you know payoff
in an
experiment so how do people then
deliberate on Collective action uh about
climate
change so this is the basic structure of
uh the experiment groups of seven were
recruited um and they first fill out a
survey to elicit their climate policy
preferences after of course consent and
information forms and then they told us
about their current carbon footprint we
took that and we assigned them to income
points 2 to six and we told them this is
your endowment uh and every two points
is worth an extra pound in this um
experiment took place in the UK now with
some probability however climate
catastrophe will happen and then you
will receive only one point of that
endowment yeah catastrophe happens it's
bad for everyone so how much tax are you
now willing to pay to avoid that this
catastroph wipes out these earnings
that's what we call the pred
predeliberation
platform there's a control group who
doesn't talk at all yeah there is a
treatment group that goes into
deliberation over Zoom yeah because that
has to be incentivized too they have to
come up with a group statement
afterwards and there's a strategic
Liberation treatment where the only
difference is that we first tell them oh
the next stage is coming up by the way
and that's a vote next stage is the vote
everyone is told about the vote if they
hadn't been told before um and when they
vote we take this text that they vote
for from this endowment that we gave
them
we also realize the catastrophe with
some probability so that if they didn't
invest enough they have a higher risk of
their earnings being uh wiped out and
then we do other things that are typical
of Behavioral experiments to elicit um
willingness to corporate risk
preferences Etc and to uh to make sure
we have measures of that to control uh
for these
things okay where are the incentives
coming from after reading the
information but but before the
deliberation and voting uh we ask them
what do you think you know which of
these five things do you think should
happen um nothing you know a low tax low
tax a high or the highest possible tax
and then we showed them you know if this
were a real vote this is what the
outcome would have been yeah so this
experiment is important to point out has
a common value by Design like we
designed it that way yeah we wanted
people to pick a higher tax because it's
protective against uh climate change
it's an um it's an insurance you can
think of it for everyone um the control
group um has no discussion but before
the vote that's also important to
mention everyone um knows the
distribution of points at least and
finally an important note to make is
that moderators were uh one moderator
was present but it was uh uh purposely
asked to stay neutral so the only thing
they did was say well this is work I'm
keeping time um maybe they would uh say
perhaps you would like to contribute and
at the end you know please write up a
group
statement what would you expect to see
well a greater willingness to choose a
higher text from the deliberation effect
that's what you expect uh from these
different um theories on deliberation
and that might be because they um their
attention is drawn by uh reading these
information or by because they gained
information or because they're persuaded
by some of the individuals that they're
talking to deliberations are very short
10 minutes
only the hypothesis on strategic uh
deliberation are somewhat different so
if you know about the upcoming election
you introduce incentives to change this
process because it might be better for
you uh financially uh if you have a
different type of outcome so it will
change the nature of the deliberation
and then in our pre-registered
experiment we had a number of more
detailed uh hypothesis but I won't go
into that too much
today so um versus the control group and
remember we have this entry voting and
outcome stage we expect to see an
outcome that deliberating groups often
more often void for a higher tax as you
would see uh in lots of these other
experiments taking place across the
world but in a strategic deliberation
you should see that they would choose
for either of these two options which
means that the total effect is noisy
yeah so this positive deliberation
effect is sort of you know decreased
somehow is uh Disturbed and the overall
effect well we can't know and then a
mechanism is something we're still
working on we're analyzing what people
said in the conversation uh the the um
the quality of the deliberation to sort
of really test which of these three
mechanisms um can explain the
deliberation
effect um should I go over the sequence
of moves once again because I know it's
a lot of things yeah also happy to come
back uh to this um these were the
materials uh for example on flying uh
first a small bit very structured this
is how much flying matters secondly
technological improvements might happen
but that's uncertain and then finally
you can do something by reducing your uh
demand same for food yeah food is
important in pollution technological
improvements may happen and solve things
but yeah demand from consumers May grow
so you can do something by reducing your
demand very
structured some initial results so this
is uh the number of groups we had um and
the number of people 378 in total and
the distribution across uh deliberation
strategic deliberation and a control
group um at at the top you see the
distribution in carbon Footprints we
forced them into and underlying that you
see the distribution in uh carbon
Footprints they actually had in the lab
yeah so you see it's not ideal we would
have preferred better distribution but
it's also not that bad yeah in terms of
uh you can see that group six pollutes
more has a higher footprint than than
group
two um this is what they told us their
initial preferences so if they cared
only about the financial incentive you
wouldn't see this you would see very
clearly that uh the people on the carbon
footprint six would you know say do
nothing and people on carbon footprint 2
would say highest reduction purely
financially uh purely based on financial
incentives but you don't see this you
see a mix of things what is important to
note though is that almost no one said
in our sample at least people that were
in our lab that they want to do nothing
yeah there were a few of those but not a
lot of people said do nothing quite a
few however said lowest please or low
reduction rather than high or
highest and this is the results so we
see the blue uh dot here that
deliberating groups more often vote for
the high text level so a high or highest
level um as uh group choices after
having spoken to each other but if we
break that up between groups who were
deliberating freely and groups who were
told before that there would be this
vote and their you know earnings would
be affected in the experiment you see a
difference uh you see uh that the
deliberating group is positive strategic
deliberation is less likely uh to
support it and the difference is
significant the green
line between these two different types
of
deliberation the final thing I want to
show you is um I talked a bit about you
know also checked entry and voting uh
and outcomes so this was outcome this
was the outcome of these groups this is
at group level here we want to look at
individuals voting so among these 370
people um did they changed their vote
from their original preferences um and
we don't see that if we leave it
unrestricted in columns one two three
but if we ask did they change their
votes away from what they were initially
saying uh they would choose to either a
high or a highest tax level as we
encourage them um to say um or as the
experiment was designed um to encourage
them to do uh we do see that it's more
likely that do deliberation treatment U
moved there um and do strategic
deliberation uh less so restricting the
sample of course to people who did not
already have the highest uh preference
in the first place because they cannot
be influenced any
further okay so to
conclude uh compared to the Baseline and
compare to each other uh we see
differences between the type of
deliberation deliberation has great
outcomes um but less so when the
deliberation is strategic the next step
is to analyze the quality of these
deliberations and to say something about
why do we see this positive effect and
what is it that these people told us in
this or you know each other and not us
directly um into why they cared about it
and why um a decision was so important
and this is just um preliminary because
it's only for parts of the sample so it
might change but we do see that the
quality of the deliberation as typically
measured in the literature was higher
among the non-strategic group uh than in
a strategic group on a number of
different um um arguments such as
neutral arguments neutral
counterarguments uh no interruptions uh
Etc so in the future the plan is to
build this up and to scale this up um
either by potentially bringing these
people together in a larger group and
then seeing uh what eventually happens
in this larger assembly or to dig in
more detail and improve the tests of the
deliberation mechanism another question
that I often have and that I'm still
thinking about I'm happy to talk about
today is whether you need to improve the
real life analogy of these experiments a
lot of people say well deliberation can
just not be measured in 10 minutes um I
say well these results actually show
that you know you can I mean there
clearly is a difference even from as
little as 10 minutes yeah so I I'm still
thinking about this part I'm not saying
it's not
important thank
[Applause]
you
okay so this is neat and I actually
think you have more in the qualitative
like the transcripts of the deliberation
um uh or you could learn a lot I my
question would be in the Strategic group
do you see evidence of you know okay I
have to convince everyone to agree so I
know I'm not going to get the tals like
it's GNA you know we're going to have to
come up with like a happy medium um or
do you see more bullying in the
Strategic group does anyone say like
well okay you know I'm going to be hurt
the most but okay I'll compromise so we
can come to like a a coordination like
the language and the tactics that people
use to delibery can you look at the text
of the groups and see differences like
what do you see
so thank you Ally that's a really good
one um actually um so we're looking at
this by using um the dqi as is common in
the literature but we're also looking at
you know whether they've used keywords
such as election majority um you know
most important preference things like
that and you know from a first Glimpse I
mean not everything has been coded yet
but it does seem to be the case that
that more often is part of the language
um for example um so yeah that's an
important one
um thank you uh Dimitri Lando NYU it
seems like the Strategic deliberation
treatment kind of the plausibility of
the Strategic deliberation treatment
kind of relies on the subjects buying
into the frame right um and so my
question is do you have exit interview
questions that give us a sense of
whether they did buy into it or not
right how much did the frame ultimately
matter to them did you say exit survey
yes yeah um I'm not sure it really
answers this this particular question we
did have an exit survey actually that we
did not incentivize as it's common in
citizen assemblies as well um we did not
find any differences people did not tell
us that they were more trustworthy or
that they were happy with the process um
uh Etc
um
yeah I mean what I mean is did they did
your subjects really understand
themselves as making a choice with
respect to climate change policy or did
they understand themselves as just
playing a game that has you know as you
said there was a like I don't know it's
a dominant strategy in the game or not
but whatever it is right for um you know
to choose a high tax so that's the
question right if they did understand
themselves as as really choosing a
climate change policy um you know
presumably we would interpret these
results somewhat differently than if we
thought this is just a you know yesing
exercise that reminds me I believe we
also asked about if you were now thought
you know if you were now thinking about
implementing this really into your own
life how would you think about reducing
you know what are sort of the efforts
you can make if I'm not mistaken it was
one of our exit questions too yeah but
can't tell you yet what it was exactly
yeah um another question I have is have
you thought about the possibility of a
join
payoff version of the Strategic
deliberation game okay so you have a
binding policy choice but their payoffs
are individual private payoffs so one
thing you might think about is you know
having a joint payoff group
payoff um see how that alters the
deliberation
uh well the tax that they were paying is
Progressive though so um the people more
um the higher pollu ERS are um more
intensively text in any case if the taex
level is that is chosen is higher so
it partly addresses that not entirely
yeah um yeah that's that's not quite we
can talk about it right if you think
about but part of the volley of doing a
joint payoff is that a joint payoff
would enable them to again see this as a
more Cooperative kind of exercise but
there's a there's I know there's a lot
going on in the experiment but we do
have the shock of climate catastrophe so
sometimes it happens that if you choose
a level of tax that is too low um you
get a draw which is bad and everyone's
payments are reduced to one so I mean in
this particular stage yeah yeah
yeah think I just have a sort of an
interpretive question um so you refer to
it as a tax but at one point you also
refer to it as insurance yeah is it
presented to them as insurance or is it
presented to them as a tax partly this
is uh I think it speaks to the colle the
collective dimensions of what they think
they're doing right so you mentioned
that you you you mentioned very uh
stressful uh you stressed that uh you
were not presupposing that there are
individual solutions to climate change
um but I think that if you think that
you can buy
insurance against climate
change that's uh precise
imposing uh a kind of an individual
solution um not in the sense of like I
can solve climate change but rather I
can buy myself out of the consequences
of climate change just wonder how that
how you present it to them experiments
like that have been done um and what you
see is the typical free rider problem
it's very hard to get Collective action
people tend to not uh put enough into
this common fund to protect uh and to
buy investment um that's why it was so
important that they would talk to each
other and make a decision collectively
as in a vote a vote which is decided by
plurality rule which is binding for
everyone also the people who did not
vote for this
yeah so I think that's precisely what
the what the experiment tries to add to
yeah experimental literature is already
out there
yeah did you say you had had uh results
on
interruptions who interrupts like or the
hide climate is it the men is it the you
know because there's large literature
especially in like the
Parliamentary uh you know committees
about like who interrupts in senior
politicians and gender you know so who
was interrupting and did it vary across
the groups and what were the
interruption results
yes so we're measuring this as part of
an item of the index so we're looking at
the number of interactions um I often
get this comment though and and um I
think it's absolutely important um but
you know we randomly assigned our
participants and we didn't really study
this aspect of the question right which
is a very important one but it's not one
we really um addressed I mean it's it's
randomly signed we might uh look at
whether there differences we could do
that yeah I mean in the in the final
outcomes right whether it affected the
conversation uh depending on these types
of characteristics as well even though
when I look at the precharacterized
right I just in general like
descriptively like across the groups do
you see like one specific type of person
more oh yeah sometimes I mean yes like I
can give you examples but I don't know
how systematic it is right this happens
yeah absolutely yeah
yeah um thank you Brenda um federa
kagati from um this is just a
clarification and it might be driven by
the fact that I I was trying to like
keep up with the presentation of the
whole project before you went into this
particular uh uh um sort of a bit and
I'm wondering did I understand correctly
that you you planning to look at
historical and online experiments at the
same time and I'm really interested
about in that and if you can just speak
a little bit more about like what's the
what you expect to see in this
comparative scenario that would be great
thank you thank
you great question thank you I can get
to be passionate about uh the project so
for example in the in in the Denmark
case that Ali presented this morning a
comment we get a lot is well these were
five groups and you know what can you
say from you know the fact that this was
only this happened only once we say well
a lot because this was a really
important uh uh context really
consequential
uh uh case and it should be studied
right we shouldn't just pick it because
it allows better statistics yeah um but
putting that into a comparative
perspective can really help us to draw
some of the these mechanisms that the
historical cases do not allow us to
investigate so does it matter how large
the group is um does it matter whether
these are seven people or 70 people uh
right does it matter by the type of the
types of decision rule they use as we
know as Ali said this morning from
electoral law should matter quite a lot
for the different outcomes you
get
yeah
yeah thank you um I want to think a
little bit more about the comparison of
the kinds of arguments that you saw
people use in the Strategic elaboration
treatment in in the non-strategic
treatment um so in the strategic
deliberation treatment you have a game
right yeah and in that game I don't know
as I said I I don't see the payoff so
but presume it's a dominant strategy is
that is that right for them to be to be
preferring the high tax it's a what it's
a is it a dominant strategy for them to
be preferring the high tax yeah I mean
it's it's a tradeoff for them yeah in
which the people who are um taxed more
highly should be preferring a lower tax
yeah okay so yeah okay fine um so but
but it's a it's a game and what they
want to do is to incentivize their
fellow players right to um to make one
set of choices as opposed to another set
of choices right and in that game
presumably they're going to be using
arguments that speak to their payoffs as
you have given to them in the game right
yeah um whereas in the non-strategic
treatment um that set of considerations
is off the table right the only relevant
considerations presumably if any are
going to be frame related considerations
which is to say it's climate change
right or do we support you know higher
lower or sort of more aggressive or less
aggressive policy in response to climate
change so in some sense it's not
surprising that you will see very
different kinds of arguments that would
be on the table right on the two kinds
of treatments mhm am I am I but
eventually the decision Remains the Same
whether you know about it before you
talk to these people or afterwards the
decision that you have to to take as a
group is the same the incentives are the
same um you know that the the financial
incentives are the same I mean so the
difference is whe whether you figure
this out before you talk to people and
whether that changes the types of
communications they have with one
another or whether you only realize this
afterwards right but the delation
treatment is the treatment without the
payoffs is that right or did I same
payoffs same payoff so what okay so
there's some aspect I'm missing so
what's the difference between the
Strategic deliver ation treatment and
delation treatment ah yeah the only
difference is that you know it before
you enter the zoom room so we tell you
everything about the election that you
will have about the policy option um
before you go into the zoom room in a
strategic treatments whereas we only
tell you this after you've been in the
zoom room in the normal uh just regular
deliberation
treatments in terms of financial
incentives and payoffs Etc everything
stays the same okay and we also have the
control group same incentives the only
difference is they don't talk so what is
your explanation for the differences in
the in the arguments that you're that
you're seeing um well we need more
support from the um measuring the
mechanism but I'm buying into this idea
that you know deliberation is going on
and you know there's an exchange of
views and people either you know spend
more attention on something uh maybe
they're really persuaded even though
they don't tell us they're persuaded in
exit surveys
um or maybe they um it's the information
that we were presented with and that
they have processed in a different way
uh when the group is in a a normal uh
deliberation environment versus a
strategic one where they know this will
have consequences for the payoffs any
experiments
very sorry uh yeah so so would you would
you just uh your your answer here about
strategic interaction maybe think about
um the Denmark example so one of the
things uh that that a question I was
sort of left with um and maybe maybe we
don't know enough about it why did they
divide up into five groups um they it
didn't seem like they were specialized
committees it seemed right they were
debating the entire document in each
group and what's interesting is if you
imagine if you can control the
deliberation of one group who is the de
decision maker then all of a sudden the
stakes are very different compared to if
there are four other groups who are all
doing the same decision right your own
like CH that changes the strategy
because being decis making um steering
your group to one decisive conclusion
would be different than for other ones
so what I'm basically what I'm thinking
of is why don't you try to mimic the
structure of the Denmark
example this might be just go be it goes
beyond this the this but um if you're
trying to test the some of these
strategic mechanisms right um it seems
like the the
context having a very different
structure might have some of these
knock-on effects when you think about
the other groups who are also
deliberating on the same question
yeah that's one possibility and an
important one and that's why I also
wanted to really present the framework
because it really fits into that I think
it's also important to keep the research
on topic like it matters because today
we're trying to get good outcomes from
these deliberative groups uh we don't
have to necessarily assume that they
will be manipulated but we can learn
from you know this these uh past cases
and you know find out whether maybe
sometimes they were or because or what
the reasons were why they were perhaps
less successful than some of the other
examples we had um and to really
understand the context and how it
influences uh the quality of uh a
deliberation
yeah thank
[Applause]
you